see you shouldn't even know it's there
where's your girl from ocean where you
been all my life
please I've been doing challenges for my
body heart mind and soul and we're at
the fourth episode JA I'm gonna be going
on the ultimate self-care experience
that means I'm gonna be going someplace
where I've never been before I'm gonna
be eating alone I'm gonna be staying by
myself and I'm just gonna be using this
time to reflect on everything that I've
learned in the first three episodes with
my body heart and mind I'm hoping that
by the end of this weekend I am feeling
calm collected less anxious less of a
mess and ready to arrive at my 30th
birthday good morning okay so I just
finished brunch by myself and I think
was really nervous at first but then
like I don't know time by yourself is so
valuable and I think we forget that I
think as women we've been socialized to
be super accommodating when there was no
one to like ask how they were feeling
and if everything was okay except myself
and I felt this deep part of me just
relax
the dates of us been pretty good I've
just been doing everything that I want
to do for one which is really nice Kurt
this fortune-teller set up shop in this
cute house on the pier
she's like as you're approaching this
new chapter in your life you need to
learn how to receive more because that's
the good part of life you know you're
working really hard and you're making
sure that you're there for your friends
I don't like it when people give me
gifts or pay me compliments you're not
gonna be able to know yourself worth
until you learn how to do this I kind of
needed to hear that today there's this
thought should I go out should I go to a
bar my soul said no I just really want
to chill I'm doing a face mask
this is ole's fresh reset when I'm on
vacation either with my family or my
boyfriend I feel like I have to kind of
like utilize every second go out every
night and do all the events I have to be
honest with you like if I truly asked
what I want right now
it's just breasts at the end of all
these challenges and as I transition to
my 30th year of life I can honestly say
that I feel better turning 30 than I did
when
21 I highly recommend setting aside some
time where you can take a look at your
body mind heart and soul set some
intentions set some challenges for
yourself just so you can kind of go into
your next year of life or go into this
next milestone feeling prepared and
feeling ready you know everything
happens for a reason and I'm here for a
reason if I am in the right spot right
now
[Music]